how to stop a heart attack what would
you do well the first thing i'm going to
say
is check with your doctor before
implementing what i'm going to tell you
this is not meant to replace your
medical care or your medication okay so
the first thing you're going to do is
call 9-1-1 of course if you have some
aspirin go ahead and take it
between 75 and 100 milligrams would help
if you've been prescribed nitroglycerin
you can take some of that that's a
vasodilator it can actually help pull
someone out of an angina attack so
what's happening when you're getting a
heart attack well you're getting a cramp
of your heart okay
because the main artery to the heart
it's called the coronary artery
is either constricted
it's going into a spasm by itself for
some reason
and then the muscle of the heart cramps
because it doesn't have enough oxygen
okay and that's what you feel when you
have chest pain so basically it's like a
muscle cramp there are several things
that can actually help that situation
when someone takes nitroglycerin for
example which by the way you may have
heard of nitroglycerin being very
explosive right well the difference
between that
and the drug nitroglycerin is the drug
is
much less concentrated okay but they're
basically the same molecule and
nitroglycerin increases something called
nitric oxide which is a
vasodilator so vasodilation increases
oxygen the main remedy i want to talk
about
is vitamin e okay in relationship to
what it can do to a heart cramp
if someone is deficient in vitamin e
what happens is they get
muscle damage
not just to the skeletal muscle but also
the cardiac muscle itself so you
actually get a breakdown of muscle
tissue when you have a vitamin e
deficiency so that's pretty wild that a
deficiency of a vitamin will cause that
much damage but it can cause extensive
degeneration
to your muscles now also with your
deficient vitamin e there'll be a
delayed repair action after you exercise
for those people that exercise on a
regular basis
they should not be doing the regular
amount of vitamin e they should be doing
extra because the more that you exercise
the more that you use your muscles
the greater the demand for vitamin e
vitamin e is a fat soluble antioxidant
and it works very powerfully on your
muscles
on your cell membranes protecting them
against oxidative stress
free radical damage
and it also works on the inside of that
artery the coronary artery to protect it
from
damage
inflammation and you can imagine when
you exercise you're generating a
tremendous amount of oxidation and free
radicals well vitamin e can actually
counter that and increase the repair
of your muscles after exercise if you're
deficient in vitamin e you're going to
feel weakness within your muscles
they're always going to be sore achy and
they're not going to be as strong so
vitamin e has been shown to effectively
repair stroke related vascular damage
and it's a very potent fat soluble
antioxidant
now
if you
do a deep dive into the research and
relationship between vitamin e
and cardiovascular accidents you're
going to find mixed reviews but if you
actually read those studies you're going
to find there's a big difference between
the type of vitamin e that they use okay
the type of vitamin e that they use when
you see negative outcomes like vitamin e
causes more heart attacks
cancer
etc they're using synthetic vitamin e
okay they're not using a food
concentrate they're not using the
natural version of the vitamin e complex
now the type of vitamin i'm going to
recommend that you you keep around the
house would be tocatrinos okay now what
is tocotrienols well it's a little
different than tocopherols they recently
discovered tokatrinos as part of the
vitamin e complex
maybe you've heard of tocopherols alpha
beta delta gamma you also have alpha
beta delta gamma to katrina's okay and
you have other things in the vitamin e
complex but the tocotrienols are much
more potent than the dicothrals they're
like 50 times stronger
so they can really
help you and also help the heart
especially when the heart needs more
oxygen so the demand for oxygen goes
down when you have enough vitamin e but
a good mix of tocotrienols would be
something i would recommend as your
vitamin e
number two
increasing
nitric oxide how do you do that
very simply you don't need anything for
this all you need to do
is slow your breath down okay and
breathe through your nose like a nice
slow inhalation
and exhalation okay back and forth
through your nose because think about it
when you're having a heart attack you're
gonna go into what's called a panic
attack right you're gonna breathe
excessively and you might hyperventilate
and guess what that's gonna do to your
heart it's actually gonna lower the
oxygen to your heart
you start building up too much co2 i
mean think about what happens when
someone's in a panic attack i mean
they're hyper ventilating quick story i
was at a restaurant with one of my old
patients and we were having lunch and
chatting
as she was consuming this soup i noticed
like she was like
you know doing this
and i'm like oh my goodness you're
choking right now in the food and and
i'm thinking okay how do i do the
heimlich maneuver and i'm just
you know running through what i have to
do really quickly so i had her stand up
and i did the heimlich maneuver from
behind and
that didn't work she's like choking her
eyeballs are popping out her face is
turning red
and what was really bizarre is everyone
sitting around the restaurant are just
standing there um
just looking at me they're not saying
anything they're like not calling 911 or
anything
so what i did is i just said
relax
just relax your throat
just don't panic
and all of a sudden that apparently
worked right it kind of brought her out
of that stress mode
because the stress creates a
vasoconstriction
the stress freezes up the nervous system
it shuts down oxygen
it can really create a situation so
anytime someone's under a panic attack
or even a heart attack they should
slow down their breathing and and
breathe at a even pace of inhalation and
exhalation through the nose okay
that will greatly help um especially the
coronary artery it's going to open it up
it's going to relax the arteries i will
put a video down below for more data on
why that works
number three if you have some garlic cod
liver oil
or nato kinase all three of these are
great natural blood thinning compounds
okay they'll thin the blood
they help reduce clots now just as a
side effect and i should probably do a
video on on strokes
but if you get a stroke the first thing
you need to do definitely is called
9-1-1 because there's a certain
medication that you can take
to if you get it in time
to help prevent the damage that's
occurring in the brain now ultimately
you want to prevent a heart attack
if you haven't seen my video on the
relationship between the benefits of
keto on the cardiovascular system and
intermittent fasting you should
definitely watch that right now
it's right here
you